foreign-born entrepreneurs account for
eighteen percent of business owners in
America immigrants today are more than
twice as likely to found businesses as
their native born counterparts more than
forty percent of the fortune 500
companies were founded by immigrants or
the children of immigrants here are the
top 50 rules for success for immigrant
entrepreneurs that third failure in a
row did you think I need to pack this in
there why not I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated
ah
here's the goal and whatever it takes to
get there I will do
so I was doing the daily work cleaning
the guns and going to the shooting range
margin 20 miles a day and rolling around
up hills with weapons running at five in
the morning with heavy combat boots and
all of this stuff and then everyone just
almost drops dead at night he's totally
exhausted I worked out three hours and
get up early in the morning again to do
my sit-ups and push-ups and lychee nuts
there was a clear conflict the dilemma
because the lifting was not a
traditional sport for them they didn't
like the idea they didn't even have the
equipment I had to go and figure out
every way possible the two dips between
chairs over the bar across two cheers
and good upset down rowing everyone
would say this is the wrong direction
that I'm going or I'm in a dream world
and I'm useless whatever it was I said
I'm going to break through that no
matter what it takes I needed to reach
dead core that vision did ahead of being
a world champion you know there's this
myth that that people think they don't
need a business plan and oftentimes I
find business owners who have an idea a
great one and where they miss it is the
execution they don't go through the
process of writing things down because
anytime you can take pen to paper and
write out your ideas and share them with
other people and get feedback which is
essentially a business plan you're going
to do better it can be a whiteboard in
an office it could be notes taken on
your computer or in a journal but I want
it to start with something that says
here's what my product or services
here's how I'm going to attack the
market here's how I'm going to beat the
competition here's how I'm going to
learn from my competitors here's what
I'm going to take from my customers and
here's the kind of people I need to
surround myself with if you don't answer
those questions then really you're just
kind of like a like a dodgeball game
you're just going to go out there and
wing it and at some point you're gonna
get whacked on the side of the head you
are the entrepreneur of your life and
you can you can you can decide you know
what you're going to do what you're
going to prioritize on
and you should never forget that you
have a tremendous amount of freedom as
it is to make these very basic decisions
on what you're going to do with your
life and even start you can start
anytime you want we're really liking
what you do whatever area that you get
into given that even if you if you're
the best the best there's always a
chance of failure so I think it's
important that you really like whatever
you're doing if you don't like it life
is too short if you like what you're
doing you think about it even when
you're not working I mean it'll just
it's something that your mind is drawn
to and and if you don't like it you just
really can't make it work I think you
see actually I do not teach you know
karate because I do not believe in
styles anymore I mean I do not believe
that there is such thing as like Chinese
way of fighting or the Japanese way of
fighting or whatever way you're fighting
because I'm less human being have three
arms and four legs we will have a
different form of fighting but basically
we have only two hands and two feet so
styles tends to a not only separate man
you know because they have their own
doctrines and then the doctrine became
the gospel cheese you know that you
cannot change you know and but if you do
not have styles if you just say well
here here i am you know as as a human
being how can i express myself totally
and completely now that way you won't
create a style because style is a
crystallization you know i mean that way
it's a process of continuing grow think
big because then you're gonna get big
then you're gonna go and achieve big
things that is the most important thing
you know we don't achieve big things by
accident so shoot for the top shoot for
the sky for that you know of for the
stars you know cash flow to me is is
important but working capital from the
beginning is also important I find that
people come to me with a projection
about their business it's a brand new
idea they think they're going to make
money in six months they don't make
money in six months and then I'll have a
cup playing they don't have a reserve
they don't have a line of credit and so
they go out of business and that's
probably the single biggest reason small
businesses closed not because the idea
is terrible now because they have bad
people it don't have the sufficient
amount of working capital the most
critical thing for every startup is to
be doing one thing uniquely well better
than anybody else in the world
technology is a fundamentally global
business and the really great technology
companies are doing something
significantly better than anybody else
in the world and you want to be in that
sort of a position I think if you're
just starting a business one of the
questions it's always valuable to answer
is what do you know that's true that
nobody else understands or more
prosaically what what great business
exists that nobody is building so many
people try to talk me out of starting a
road company it was it was crazy one
good friend of mine collected a whole
series of videos of rockets blowing up
and maybe watch those you just didn't
want me to lose all my money we're doing
these things that seem unlikely to
succeed and we've been fortunate and
this thus far they have succeeded when I
look around I always learn something
that is to be always yourself and to
express yourself to have faith in
yourself do not go out and look for a
successful personality and duplicate him
now that seems to me that that is the
prevalent thing happening in Hong Kong
like they always copy mannerism but they
never start from the very root of his
being and that is how can I be meaning
all of those liabilities that they
talked about started turning into assets
when it had Conan the Barbarian the
director came to me and he said if we
wouldn't have you we wouldn't have to
build one and on terminator the director
said I couldn't imagine to have anyone
play terminated it wouldn't have an
accident and they wouldn't have your
body I cannot imagine the line I'll be
back with a normal American accent
it works so perfectly than you have this
German accent so all of those things
that they say the liabilities became an
acid the moment as moment went on a grew
and grew and I went from one movie to
the next sort of making more and more
money and then aunt ended up being the
highest paid actor with 30 million
dollars and Terminator 3 one of the
things that I do do before I go to bed
at night is that make a quick list of
the things that I know I have to deal
with the next day and I try to get those
knocked out before noon because from
noon on it's kind of like the wild wild
west I don't know what's going to happen
I don't know what new issues going to
come up and so you want to really be
smart about your time to knock out the
things that you have to who do I have to
talk to what do I have to review what do
I have to do with a bank or an employee
or one of the businesses you want to get
out what I would call the housekeeping
you get the housekeeping done in the
morning and then you get to kind of go
farm the fields for the rest of the day
and part of the challenge or part of the
challenge for me at least is that that
lines get very blurry of when the day
actually shuts off and that can present
a real challenge to you know your
personal life and your friends and in
kind of that balance so it's it's hard
but the first part of my day is the
focus one part that I'm always I'm very
focused on sort of the structure of
these companies and how well our people
align and so you can and making sure
that people are you know aligned
properly not just that they say that I
think this is sort of a very very legal
kind of a framework to think about what
are people's incentives you know are
they going to be lined or not and I
think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have informal
alignment where the people would
naturally try to work together well in
one one way or another um and I think
that's somehow tends to get obscured in
all these other ways on you know there's
always a there's always a there's always
a prehistory question I like to ask
founders of companies which is how did
you how did you meet what's the
prehistory of the company before you got
started
and I find that to be really instructive
set of questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
start a company because we both wanted
to be entrepreneurs you know that's like
saying I married the first person I met
at the slot machines in Las Vegas and
you might hit the jackpot but it's
probably a really bad idea and a much
better answer is you know we've been
talking about this for a long time you
know maybe one of us is more on the tech
side the other ones more on the business
side we have these sort of complementary
skills and and so I think this question
of a lion and structure is um is
incredibly important now is the time to
take risk you don't have kids as you get
older your obligations increase so
you're and once you have a family you
start taking risk not just for yourself
but for your family as well it gets much
harder to do things that might not work
out so now is the time to do that before
you before you have those obligations so
I would encourage you to take risks now
do something bold you won't regret it a
good martial artist does not become
tense but ready not thinking yet not
dreaming ready for whatever may come
when the opponent expand like contract
when he contracts I expand and when
there is an opportunity I do not it
it hits all by itself thomas be the same
bar bodybuilding enhancing ha Tik
technique she came on to be a young son
Thomas in my sock k honoured one strives
lady neither the fountain Alton house
this way I getting it C average my
father he said this is an embarrassment
to me and was stomping all over me tell
you we need you here and this is more
important than any pie will ever make
but I'm gonna need your help before you
leave cuz I gotta get some stuff done
and you're gonna be our leader here okay
okay but in order for you to be able to
have a good piece of mind I wanted to
give you some money I'm gonna give you
six months worth of pay ok when you come
back you will be fully in charge of this
location and I'm gonna pay you a
thousand dollars a week so you don't
have to bartend ok ok I'm gonna give you
a check and it should help you just kind
of just be able to rest take care of
your baby and then when you come back
you're gonna bust somebody's ass ok
wow thank you the reality of it is is
that the employee is number one because
if the employees happy ultimately the
customers going to be happy if the
employees happy they're going to take
care of the assets of your business if
the employee is happy they will have a
pride of ownership and they'll stand
side-by-side with you and they'll fight
during the tough times and they'll
celebrate during the good times if you
take care of your employees they will
put the customer first but if you don't
it won't matter there won't be any
customers you don't take care of your
employees there'll be nobody to help
them you'll have no business I think
that on all if yours founder or
entrepreneur what you want to aim for is
monopoly you want to aim to build a
company that is one of a kind and that
it's so far differentiated from the
competition that it's not even competing
and I think this is the conventional
wisdoms always a capitalism and
competition are somehow synonyms I
believe they're antonyms a capitalist is
someone who's in the business of
accumulating capital a world of perfect
competition is a world where all the
prophets are competed away if you want
to compete like crazy then you should
just open a restaurant in Chicago and
and and i think the the great companies
like google so the paradigm example i
use has had no serious competition and
search since 2002 when it definitively
distance itself from Yahoo and Microsoft
and as a result that's been generating
enormous cash flows for the last 12
years how did you figure you were gonna
start a car company and be successful at
it well I didn't really think Tesla
would be successful I thought we would
most likely fail but I thought that we
at least could address the false
perception that people had that an
electric car had to be ugly and slow and
and boring like a golf cart but you say
you didn't expect the company be
successful then why try if something's
important enough you should try even if
probable outcome is failure one time
people come up and say hey groups are
you really that good I said well if I
tell you I'm good probably you will stay
on boasting if I tell you I'm no good
you know one line the other thing is is
that you get to work your butt off if
you think that you're gonna go and
accomplish something really special and
be the best in anything in the world and
you think you can do it without working
you make a big mistake because no matter
what I did if it was a bodybuilding or
an acting or if it is in the political
arena it always took a lot a lot of work
and you gotta put out and you got the
you know something to make a lot of
sacrifices notice if you're not willing
to work hard forget about it is another
rule that is a very important I say
follow your passion which should be
sports I say if you have a passion for
business you also better have a
knowledge for it and so if people want
to own a business they better have
worked for somebody else for a while and
they better have an intrinsic knowledge
of that industry and so it would be like
me getting into you know the barber
business and I never went to learn how
to cut hair I shouldn't have a knowledge
if I don't have the knowledge then I
better have a partner or I better have a
manager or a leader in place who's
vested in the business who does have a
knowledge and so three guys want to open
up a restaurant because they think it's
cooled open up a restaurant but none of
them not to cook or suede tables they
shouldn't be in that business but yeah
there probably are a lot of people who
who end up trying to be sort of so much
fake entrepreneurs where the goal is to
be an entrepreneur um if you ask you
what do you want to do with your life
what do you want do when you grow up I
want to be an entrepreneur which i
always think is a somewhat too common
something disturbingly somewhat too
common and I think you know it's it's up
it's on and you know it's saying that
you want to be an entrepreneur is sort
of like saying I want to be rich I want
to be famous you know nobody in their
right mind starts a company for the sake
of starting a company you start a
company because there's a very important
problem to solve that's not getting
solved enlarge you know governmental or
nonprofit or for-profit institutions and
that's why you actually
to start a new company just starting a
company for the sake of doing so is a is
a really odd thing to do we focus on on
signal over noise a lot of companies get
get confused that they spend money on
things that don't actually make the
product better for example at Tesla
we've never spent any money on
advertising we put all the money into
R&D and manufacturing and design to try
to make the car as good as possible and
i think that's that's the way to go
before for any given company just keep
thinking about are these efforts that
people are expending are they resulting
in a better product or service if
they're not stop those efforts i said
empty your mind be formless shapeless
like water now you put water into a cup
it becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you put it
in a teapot it becomes the teapot now
water can flow or it can crash be water
my friend use your power of potential
and make this nation in this world a
better place it worked for this
immigrant that came over here to this
country with twenty dollars in the
pocket and I know and I guarantee you
will work for you to entrepreneurs who
have authored a product or a process
that isn't working today have to make
the bold step of reinventing themselves
I talk about it all the time how over
the course of my life whether it was at
12 years old or 18 years old or 25 years
old or even today I'm constantly working
to reinvent myself I'm not any different
than a package on a shelf people have to
feel that it's relevant they have to see
the warning labels they have to
understand the contents it has to be
appealing it has to provide value to
people and so when an entrepreneur has a
product or a process that they've
authored and they're not willing to
change it then they're going to end up
like Circuit City or Montgomery Ward or
sears or Fiat or whatever these brands
are that don't exist anymore right every
single company
in this country today if they're not
evolving they're dying and i don't know
why an entrepreneur would think that
they would be exempt from that process
I'm not interested in their ego I'm not
interested in their pride i'm not
interested in their feelings i'm
interested in their business being
successful and so i think not only does
their business have to do it but but we
as entrepreneurs have to do it as well
on an individual level I think it is
always it's always really good if if
there's something that you're incredibly
passionate about and and just sort of
our fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that and
so that you know one of the one of the
the resolutions I came up with a number
of years ago was to always value
substance over status substance over
prestige and you know if I sort of it
was giving my younger self advice on
what to what to do or how to how to
think about your one's one's life I you
know I probably I think I you know I
probably still go to Stanford you know I
might still go to law school but I'd ask
I'd ask sort of I'd ask a lot more
questions why I was doing these things
and I think I think if I was honest
about it too much of it was driven by
buy prestige and status and not quite
enough about really the substance of
trying to learn things and the other
heads for this I sort of think of it
it's this sort of crazy rolling quarter
life crisis and sort of culminated in
this in this you know big New York law
firm where you know from the outside
everybody wanted to get in from the
inside everybody wanted to get out you
know after I lasted seven months and
three days and after and when I when I
when I left one of the people down the
hall said it's so reassuring to see you
leave Peter I had no idea it was
possible to escape from alcatraz which
which again and you know and again I and
all you had to do is go through the
front door but our identity people's
identities get so wrapped up and the
things they compete for that it was
inconceivable for people to act
they do that and and then the question
was you know well how had I ended up
there why had I not thought about that
more and and I think it was that I had
taken too many of these shortcuts of
valuing sort of what was prestigious
what was conventional over what I would
I really want to do so I think I think
always substance over status when
interview someone to work at the
company's would be to ask him to tell me
about the problems that they worked on
and how they sold them and if someone
was really the person has solved it
they'll be able to answer multiple
levels they'll be able to go down to the
brass tacks and if they weren't they'll
get stuck and then you can say oh this
person was not really the person who
solved it because anyone who struggled
hard with a problem never forgets it in
case you have missed the reasoned news
she could know of which I am the
farmville has been elected and
acceptable to the black belt hall of
fame in America this must the first time
a recently developed form of martial art
is nationally accepted no she can throw
is not thousands or even hundreds of
years old it started in around nineteen
sixty-five by a dedicated and
intensified man call bruce lee and my
martial art is something that no serious
martial artist can ignore i said i
wanted to get into acting people said no
you have an accent and you have a body
that is too big and you name the one can
pronounce be realistic it's the 70s day
Dustin Hoffman he's the big shot Al
Pacino little guys Woody Allen sex
simple even when i ran for governor
visits are you kidding me i mean he can
never win give it up
but I didn't pay any attention because
it amiss if what did i do when they said
you can't go to German you can compete
in a junior mr. Europe that I did not
listen to the note I went and it worked
out and I used that attitude as a
blueprint for the rest of my life let's
talk about the myth that your product is
already good enough people often develop
a new product and it's fantastic and it
hits the market like in a blaze of glory
and it sells and there's back orders if
you're delivering them a good product or
service today they're still going to
expect something better tomorrow and the
one thing you have to worry about is
there's a competitor out there somebody
they can mimic your offering and so you
always have to stay one step ahead of
them and so when products don't morph
into something new they don't develop
into something better and smarter and
faster and less expensive it's probably
the biggest takeaway less expensive then
people are going to find alternatives
for me I'd like to go out and study the
competition that's how I reinvent myself
I go out and I study businesses aren't
exactly the same but they run their
business with a set of ethics and a set
of principles that are second to none
and they can be in a space that's
completely different than mine but I
learned something from them I don't
think we do that enough and this is why
think competition is always this very to
edge thing when you compete ferociously
you will get better at that which you
are competing on but you will always
narrow your focus to beating the people
around you and and it often comes at
this very high price of losing sight of
what is more important or perhaps more
valuable if you're creating company or
if you're joining a company the most
important thing is to is to attract
great people so either be would join a
group that's amazing that you've really
respect or if you're building a company
you've got to gather great people i mean
all the company is is a group of people
that have gathered together to create a
product or service and so depending upon
how talented
hard-working that group is an degree to
which they are focused cohesively in a
good direction that will determine the
success of the company so do everything
you can to to gather great people if
you're creating a company I have no fear
of opponent in front of me but I am very
self-sufficient then they do not bother
me and that should I fight should I do
anything I have made up my mind and
that's it baby you better kill me before
don't be afraid to fail because if
you're afraid to fail then you're always
holding yourself back because you're
afraid that if you go all out you may
fail well in weightlifting we learned it
very quickly the only way you could
break a record is if you're willing to
fail that's when you put on more weight
you try it sometimes you may be done you
will not be able to lift it we just
happened to me many times but eventually
when you train hard enough you will lift
it so don't be afraid to fail you I mean
how far can you fall how many people you
meet at a party or at a restaurant to
tell you they're entrepreneurs and in
the past I used to say no does that mean
you don't work and so an entrepreneur to
me is is kind of a nonsensical word
you're either a business owner or you
are a team member one of the two and I
think being a business owner is the
hardest thing to do in this country you
take your money hopefully not your
mother's money but you take your money
and you invest in an idea which is
essentially investing in yourself but if
you do it solely to make money you're
going to lose and you really have to do
it and I know that a lot of people out
there get up every morning in the
household okay and they're driving in
the car right now and they're on the way
to a job that they may not love yeah and
I would encourage them just to stick to
the grind get the paycheck pay the bills
learn learn and learning too many young
kids out of college tell me they're
entrepreneurs and I tell them you can't
be an entrepreneur until you've worked
for somebody else and you know what it
feels like to be fired right to be
called on the mat or to be harassed or
to be mismanaged you got to know what
that feels like so that when you're on
the other side yeah you can be
respectful to people yeah
general theme I would suggest is that
all trends are overrated and so if you
think about current trends in technology
you know healthcare IT software
education software overrated SAS
enterprise software really overrated Big
Data cloud computing if you hear those
words you need to think fraud you need
to run away as fast as you possibly can
and and the reason these buzzwords um
tell you that something is that there's
these buzzwords are sort of like a tell
in poker that people are bluffing and
that there's nothing that there's that
the business is not undifferentiated
because the buzzwords tell you that it
is one company of a category that's
undifferentiated from the others in that
category and therefore are symptomatic
somehow of a lot of competition and a
bad a bad business idea and so you know
you don't want to be the fourth online
pet food company you don't want to be
the tenth thin-film solar panel company
you don't want to be the 1000th
restaurant in San Francisco and so there
is something about if you can describe
what a company is doing very
straightforwardly by referencing on
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist that's actually a
sign that it's a pretty bad that's
that's a pretty bad idea we've got to
make sure that whatever you're doing is
a great product or service it has to be
really great and I go back to what I was
saying earlier where if you're a new
company I mean this is like some new
industry or new market that if it's an
untapped market or then then you have
more ability to give is this the
standard is lower for your product or
service but if you're entering anything
where there's an existing market place
against large entrenched competitors
then your product or service needs to be
much better than theirs it can't be a
little bit better because then you put
yourself in the shoes of the consumer
and they say why would you buy it as a
consumer you're always going to buy the
trusted brand
unless there's a big difference so a lot
of times you know entrepreneur will come
up with something which is only slightly
better and it's it's not you can't just
be slightly better it's got to be a lot
better what was that an exhibition we
emotional content try again how did if
you kill you let me think I think feel
it is like a finger pointing away to the
moon don't concentrate on the finger or
you will miss all that heavenly glory in
Austria kids were conditioned evallo
parents path but unlike other kids
around me I was very determined that I
have to get out of there and then one
day I saw the cover of a magazine of reg
Park then it says how mr. universe
became Hercules I opened up this
magazine and the red fluid and there was
the whole plan lay down ask yourself a
nerd what is it about you it is so
different why are you the only one that
sees it so clearly the score going the
American winning the Mr Universe contest
and getting in the move is in making
millions of dollars no one else talks
about this amount here is it real is it
just a crazy fantasy but wait a minute
French Park did it then it's possible i
know'd focus the key thing is to be
focused visualizing call and I saw
myself standing up to the stage just
like rich park and it became more
more clear Arnold you've got to go you
know I have a terrible fear that I lay
awake at night with and that's the fear
of failure and the embarrassment that
comes with it and so people like to have
a lot of pride and say and I'm I'm not
embarrassed I'm not I think anybody
that's an entrepreneur deep down really
deep down in their soul has fear of
failure what will people say what will
people think and it's hard it's a hard
challenge and so I try to ignore it as
much as I can but I I find it kind of
haunting me and so I push through
because I really believe that I have an
obligation to keep trying and trying and
trying and I've had plenty of failure in
my life what happened was when I turned
35 in 2008-9 happened I became much more
comfortable with admitting my
vulnerability acknowledging my mistakes
saying when I was wrong showing my cards
and saying I was stupid crumbs could be
one of those situations where I tried to
outsmart something and now I don't think
it's going to fail but I have to be
realistic it could anything I do could
fail I think there's a problem in in
Western Europe where where failure is
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over I think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in California
where I think sometimes people are a
little bit too facile about failure
because I I think it actually is always
incredibly damaging to people and if you
work really hard at something and it
doesn't work on that's you know that's
that's going to be psychologically
damaging you know people have less
confidence you to all sorts of reasons
why why that tends to be that tends to
be quite bad I think that I think when
people I don't think there's that much
you learn from failure by the way
because it's typically overdetermined
it's likewise technology slowing down
why did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you work with the wrong
people the idea was bad timing was wrong
it wasn't a monopoly
didn't work on and okay next time i'm
working with different people you figure
out one out of the five things you're
likely to fail fail again so i think i
think failure is not something one can
learn very much from i think that's sort
of a myth that I I would challenge but
what I think what I think you should do
when you when something goes badly wrong
is you just keep going you do something
else ah and you don't dwell on the past
did anyone help well you want to do in
particular eight you're starting a
company you need to work super hot so
what is super hard mean well when my
brother and I were starting our first
company instead of getting an apartment
we just rented a small office and we
slept on the couch and we showered at
the YMCA and we're so hot up we had one
computer so the website was up during
the day and I was coding at night seven
days a week all the time and I I should
briefly had a gopher in that period and
in order to deal with me chefs asleep in
the office so I work hard like and it
mean every waking hour that's that's the
the thing i would i would say if you're
particularly if you're starting a
company and I mean if you do simple math
to say like okay if somebody else is
working 50 hours when you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as the other
company well you know everyone talks to
me about Bruce Lee because Bruce Lee and
I were very good friends and we trained
together for like three years before he
left for Hong Kong to pursue his movie
career and I didn't hear anything from
Bruce for like two years then out of the
blue Bruce calls me he says I've done
two movies in Hong Kong and they're
really successful I want to do a movie
now with a fight scene that everyone
will remember and I want to do the fight
scene and the Colosseum in Rome and I
want you to be my opponent at that time
I held the world title and kiddingly I
say to Bruce I said well who wins Bruce
and he said I win I'm the star of this
movie and I said oh I see you want to
beat the world
Ian he said no i don't i want to kill
the world champion
that just shows you again so much for it
can't be done this is why I try to tell
you anything and everything can be done
if you can visualize it and if you
believe in yourself it was the same
thing again when i ran for governor you
can imagine when i went on at the night
show and i announced that i'm gonna run
for governor of the great state of
California people came to me after
witnesses you're crazy you don't
announce something like this under
tonight show you have an official press
conference at the State Capitol plus you
don't start with governorship you go
start first with mayor or which state
senator and I said I don't want to be
senator I don't want to be mayor I want
to be governor don't you understand that
well the rest is history I one in 2003
and the one also in 2006 let me tell you
you're going to find the naysayers in
every turn that you make don't listen
just visualize your goal know exactly
where you want to go trust yourself get
out there and Brooke like hell and break
some of the rules and never ever be
afraid of failure I go through thousands
and thousands of applications and
sometimes I pick businesses that are new
and innovative in the products exciting
and sometimes I pick businesses that are
pretty ordinary when its ordinary and
its saturated biggest challenges you're
now dealing with the commodity and so
whether it's a coffee shop or a yogurt
shop the question is is the product
relevant in the marketplace and if it's
saturated can you rise to the top of the
list I want to encourage people not to
run away from saturated markets but I
want you to run away if you don't have
the time the resources the energy the
people the process or the attention to
detail to be best in class and so if
you're going to open up a coffee shop in
a very crowded market you better have
something that's unique it better be
experiential your product better be
amazing your process better be
on point and the people that sell it
better be better in product knowledge
and better and experience than anything
else I guess a different way to look at
it is if you go into an industry that's
not saturated you should probably ask
yourself is there a reason that nobody
else is in this I can't be the only
person with this idea and so you get
into a business that's not saturated it
may tell you that there's not really a
market there I think I'd like to get
into the hangar business I mean is it
saturated is it not is there a reason
that everybody is that in it I don't
really mind whether it's saturated or
not I have to like the product it has to
be relatable and it has to be not
totally recession proof but it has to be
kind of recession proof I think it's
important that if you're going to get
into a business and you're thinking
about taking your last fifty thousand
dollars in getting it getting into
something you better have something that
is unique if it's going to be a
commodity and you better better make
sure that you really understand what
happens when the economy goes up and
down and study those trends already in
the time of Shakespeare the word aight
meant both primate and to imitate and
there is something very deep and human
nature that is imitative it's how it has
a lot of good things that's how language
gets learned by kids it's how culture
gets transmitted in our society but it
also can lead to sort of a lot of insane
behavior lead to the madness of crowds
to bubbles to to sort of mass delusions
of one sort or another and and I think
it can and I think it's you know
advertising we always think of we always
tell ourselves that were not that prone
to this and I think that's something i'd
encourage all of us to rethink and we
always think of advertising is something
that just afflicts other people that
never have plates ourselves I think this
is very far from the case and so and so
the monopoly competition is not just
this intellectual failure it's also this
thing where you have a tiny door where
everyone's trying to rush through and
there may be around the corner a vast
and a secret gate that no one's taking
and you should always find the secret
path and go ahead and take that thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video we're looking for
other ideas for what you'd want to see
in the top
50 series so if you have a suggestion or
a thought leave it in the comment below
I'd also love to know which of the rules
stuck out I meant the most to you leave
it in the comments and I will join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching did you believe and I'll see
you soon